[Music]
my favorite Instagram filter would be
slumber that is my best friend she we
were up together in San Diego and we're
still best friend for going on a trip
with down to this one I've never done
Instagram live but I've been in other
people's Instagram life my dad is a
painter and taught art for many many
years so I think if except with him and
then I was an art major I feel like I
went to the airport after Trump proposed
his travel ban and that was a sign that
I made for that and then I ended up
making a t-shirt at benefit at the ACLU
[Music]
Nicki Minaj follows me and I love Nicki
Minaj and when she liked the post I'm
like I'll never delete totally I love
Sofia Loren definitely Nikon how do you
split Bianca Jagger Audrey Hepburn
family is everything I'm an only child
so I'm super close with my parents as
the most important people my texting
so that was a day when Planned
Parenthood was getting threatened for
serious cuts in the Senate in the house
so I post that in support of Planned
Parenthood no but I love her she's
gorgeous yes that is my really good
friends dog and I get two dogs at him
all the time and it was moose and he's
the best he's a thug and I want to stay
and just is everything I mean I think
that the relationships that you build
these people define who you are so this
was right after Trump was elected and I
was actually straight off a plane and
you know I think that the March was sort
of like a general March it wasn't for
one specific thing but for many
different issues and so I chose to talk
about something that was really near and
dear to me and use a quote from Naomi
Wolf one of my favorite feminist writer
you